suona però detto io che non so suonare
non hai bisogno di suonare va bene 20
solo lo spartito non fare niente a falun
e moderno pianoforti moderni non li
suoni si suonano da soli per forte
inizia a suonare da solo il bano si è
scossa e ha sputato fuori un kia vino
grazie del chiarino colore
ringrazio del chiarino sembra roba
bruttissima da dire ma va bene tu stai
fermo e calmo e zitto pur se acceso una
fiamma devo accedere al 34 devo
accenderle vichiano accesa a malapena
una se sono al carillon con il 12 al 12
la carta del re quindi col chiarino ok
[Musica]
eh no dai però è paleo maggio enjoy the
music è perfetto cosa fa dovevo fare il
tamburi sta il tamburellista andate un
chiamino del 12 posso essere il sole
possono essere sabbia e posso essere un
uccello è che puoi andare a fare una
cosa sono anche tra queste cose qua a
orologio sabbia desidera sole la
meridiana è un uccello a cucù va a
cagare
ok giusto corretto grazie schiavino è
caduta a terra cavino con una regina
bene negli anni sabbia che siederà un
cielo orologio avevo capito già lancia
ha bisogno di grazie sono intelligente
lo sapevo e so 2 accese bene ne mancano
cannes due anche se non ho capito la
quarta con le dovrebbe essere prove
prendiamo un tè no va bene sono al 12
vittime nel reggino vai dalla stessa
musica di prima quindi in teoria la
guardia mi dovrebbe uccidere
però stavolta no ma benché ho fatto
allora rumore di soprano mara sinistro
ma la destra
questa norma già fatto anno ecco un
grande orologio non ticchetta schiavino
schiavino in sé cerchia vino grande non
riesce a raggiungere l'orologio 6 10 la
sedia
meno male che sotto o stato difficile
sta parte non mi ricordavo michael
chiamino editor chiavi noel ha girato
bene sono è stato fatto in tutte le
stanze bene senti qualcosa sboccarsi
oggi su grazie via di qua ti sta bene
testa di culo quale potessi ti
ammazzerei le gambe sono piegate ti
piegherai anche il cervello guarda
sempre se ce l'hai porta aperta calmi e
che già non mi piace sta suo mood una
statua di una donna che piange parla
perché piangi il mio anello non è qui da
avrà dato all'amante come bloccato vuoi
dalla vita mia da fatte gorna colpa mia
no
ma chi è in cammino
guarda dentro o muoio trova un anello
c'è un buco ad una scala di ferro che
scende e scendi no
ora cav h devo entra
entra entra a prima porta sta succedendo
qui c'è la porta
no a prima porta che è la dispensa mi sa
che non è proprio il massimo e tregua
dente fa se poteva anche evitare di
farlo tanto credo ci sia ci sono delle
bacchette nelle costo dello scheletro
prendi delle bacchette camera fa vabbè
via via via porca vacca via veloce per
stato un coso lì ancora di più bene via
fortissimo non si apre
hai bisogno dei miei spazi la pentola
bolle spegne spegne il fuoco a genna
scendi che pronto è pronto genna pronti
ma non è che devo fare
cerca con le vado cercando la ventola
cover chi ancora sulla pentola e togli
lo aprì coperchio guarda odora odora
sentire buon odore di carciofi morti non
stima volto il tuo appetito a uno strano
odore cercato le bacchette cazzo stai
cercando pento an che c'ha il mestolo di
zia pina le bacchette hanno preso
qualcosa ti vedo zio hai ottenuto un
anello di maglia un anello di maiale mi
scusi lei la camera dei dell'iss che le
tribù ella non c'entro più non c'entro
più perché non c'è l'audio che brutto
quando non c'e l'audio non è vero nesta
potrebbe essere un problema non è che
theory dalle bacchette
trinità è tenere i dotti eni metti a
posto le bacchette dove ma che cosa sta
minkia le so io
nelle coste potenti proprio te le
bacchette tra le coste dello scheletro
marone lugar piano è piano ora gara
giusto non ci posso credere
muoviamoci aperti che dici senti
qualcuno scendere dalle scale si l'ho
sentito via via via via però via via
brutta [ __ ] suo anello di merde del
maiale tra l'altro il prendi telo
madonna che ansia lega sta diventando un
ansia questo è il mio grazie
senti qualcosa a sbloccarsi da voi che
parte la porta si apre mamma mia ragazza
esteri netta per maschile per forza
rompere qualcosa ogni volta che
attraverso una porta che ha rotto le
palle io soprattutto
grazie gentili grazie mi ha salvato il
culetto la strega non ho capito cos'era
quella roba prova la vetrata si è
frantumata è buio pesto fuori quindi la
strega mi ha salvato il culo devo pure
ringraziarla in tutto questo quella che
per bloccare figurati a demo riordina le
bambole nel posto giusto giustamente ok
perfetto ha posto la porta si è aperta
ok con mentre una porta succede sempre
qualcosa o acciaio gatto mi chiami
mancato guarda io ho frate yacht
pare che questo sia l'ultimo piano se
davvero questo è l'ultimo piano della
casa che ne sa il gatto delle palle
belfiore ciao come stai bene grazie
signor fiore sto benissimo
gli uccelli mangiano le piante verdi sì
mi fa più quindi devo trovare un uccello
sono sicuri
va bene
è un uccello un altra roba alle piante
verdi prendono il tè allo zenzero questa
roba voi non lo sapevate scommetto io lo
sapevo se non lo sapevate sapevatelo
grande loro agio il tempo scorre tocca
male stiamo gli orologi nulla ti
colpisce
beh qualcosa mi ha colpito in realtà se
vogliamo proprio essere sincere brown ha
fatto più male questo ricondotti de
monetizzano i video rai non tocchiamo e
gli orologi che sono degli stronzi queen
e ora guarda sotto il tavolo c'è un
rischio per terra prendi aiutato un
teschio che sta roba timore è macchiato
di rosso la piccina marzo trovando roche
in nascoste dico le chiatte prendono te
onestamente lei proprio lasecchia
bellissimo e l'altra cosa ha risposto oh
cielo ai delle braccia delle grosse
orobiche trip ti devi fare prima di
giocare sta roba famme capì noah dimmelo
o perché qualcuno non hicks quella
ragazza
se qualcuno lo facesse assi
condivideremo un po del nostro bel
polline e pensare che senza di lei
saremo le più belle del giardino è vero
che sul grande riga soprattutto fatto xe
i fiori e morirei anche tu no no io non
lyxor i fiori stai tranquillo io l'ho
nixon nessuno non vi preoccupate è buio
pesto là dentro non c'è vero scusate
fiori se vi ho disturbati mentre
facevate l'aperitivo d'aperitivo figata
ecco i fiorellini e le belle fir libro
intitolato le piante chiacchierone leggi
i fiori sono bellissime possono parlare
sì me ne sono accorto possono anche
spettegolare tipo di ragazze queste sono
le loro caratteristiche
i fiori bianchi sono i più belli nel
giardino se toccati dalla pioggia i loro
petali e splende le erbe rosse sono ben
informate ma dicono sempre le bugie
tensione quando chiacchieri con loro va
bene per i gialli sono sospettosamente
adorabili il polline prodotto da questi
fiori una fonte di medicina che può
uccidere o dare vita mi è andato in trip
il cervello non mi ricordo più una sega
ma continuiamo medicina è bloccata
qualcuno si lamenta lì dentro parla wade
a cook medicina ne hai un po no ti ha
sputato addosso ma tua madre gonorrea ma
che problemi hai malato di merda e la
tachipirina va a parte da comprare testa
di culo una gabbietta di metallo aprì la
porticina e fermamente chiusa guarda la
qual cosa batte debolmente le sue ali
adottiva lucia 88 l'uccello rega questo
sono le piante rosse bastard delle
piante rosse vuoi sapere come si hicks
un fiore se nessuno dei tre modi di
hicks sono giusti dovessi solo hicks
credo voglia dire uccidere a questo
punto non lo so dovessi solo lasciar
perdere
ho dimenticato qual è il modo giusto per
un hicks e la tipo tagliarlo sradicarlo
sradicare cogliere sono entrambi i modi
giusti per hicks
vabbè bloccate buio pesto o salve lei è
nuovo
c'è un piccolo teschio sua sedia ma no
aspettate ma non già uno prendi prendi
anche questa dai aiuto un teschio cielo
due adesso che bello bello faccio
collezioni di teschi lega sempre stato
il mio sogno o l'erba verde posso andare
di qua c'è un fosso un grande buco senza
un fondo visibile poverino di sradicarlo
stappa mi sa che sei incazzato però coi
cogli lo colga
posso cogliere con uno strano urlo il
bel fiore svanisce ma poverino dei
petali bianchi sono spazi per terra
prendi hai tutto petali di fiore grazie
madonna quanto krypi questo posto
ragazzi volevo concludere qui l'episodio
di the witch house
il prossimo sarà l'ultimo niente spero
che la serie vi stia piacendo come senso
quanto mi piace che ci ha condotto da
tiziana so sempre si chiede non ci
vediamo da ragazzi
[Musica]